if
what i'm about to say is not eye-opening
i
don't know
what would be hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
we will be discussing the intersection
between digestive and eating disorders
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor sundance now i have barely left
my house over the past two years
but if anything has gotten me through
this
it's been a good tv series so we
recently got a subscription to sundance
now which is an ad streaming service
created by amc networks for folks like
me who want really solid storytelling
and fresh perspectives they have
original dramas thrillers and my
favorite lots of true crime i mean i
watch an unusual amount of true crime
my hobbyist low-key scared of me as he
should be but they have weekly releases
and hundreds of exclusive shows that you
won't find anywhere else in a variety of
genres that the whole family will love
right now i am totally obsessed with
their original series a discovery of
witches i'm not usually into fantasy but
i'm just so in love with the characters
and the storyline is so strangely
addictive so you can stream sundance now
on all apple or android devices amazon
fire tv google chromecast or roku for
just 4.99 a month with no annoying
commercial interruptions and as a
special gift to my followers you can try
sundance now for free for 30 days by
going to
sundancenow.com and using my promo code
abby sharp and don't forget to come back
here to the comments to let us all know
what shows you are loving right now and
don't forget to pause the screen to look
at the description including a huge
trigger warning for folks with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating i will be discussing common ed
behaviors so as always feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and don't forget to
subscribe to this channel if you're not
already ring that little bell and follow
me over on tik tok and instagram okay so
for folks who may be new here
you may not know a lot about my personal
medical history but in short when i was
a teenager i had a pretty severe eating
disorder and almost 20 years later now
i'm still dealing with some of the
potential repercussions
most notably with my ibs and my now sibo
diagnosis which i have been working
through in my series right here now in
my video about my eating disorder i
mentioned that eating disorders and
digestive disorders frequently present
together one study found that of women
diagnosed with an eating disorder 50
met the criteria for ibs and 98
met the criteria for at least one
functional gut disorder and while most
evidence suggests that the eating
disorder often comes first
we are dealing with a very complicated
chicken in the egg situation so what are
the major factors bridging digestive and
eating disorders get ready to learn a
lot first of all let's talk about poor
gut motility so severe caloric
restriction literally starves the vital
organs and in most severe cases
this is why eating disorders can result
in heart failure and even death but
naturally this means the digestive
organs start to atrophy
which can lead to constipation bloating
gas and gastroparesis aka poor gut
motility so research suggests that
bloating is significantly higher in
individuals with eds as is experiences
like nausea acid reflux and prolonged
fullness after a meal and since a lot of
folks with disordered eating histories
are
hyper aware of their body sensations if
they experience bloating after eating
something this can often be interpreted
as feeling fat or gaining weight even
which of course can then hinder their
progress towards recovery so second is
the dysbiosis of the gut so you guys
always hear me say that variety is the
spice of life
and that's not just for feeding yourself
but also for feeding your gut bacteria
as well so limited food variety can
disrupt the balance of bacteria in the
gut and digestive enzyme production
while potentially also exacerbating or
causing food intolerances so for example
if you were to completely remove dairy
from your diet because some influencer
told you dairy is toxic
your body will cease production of the
enzymes needed to digest dairy then
maybe when you slip up or you have a
cheat day and you have some ice cream
you'll likely feel really really really
sick which then reinforces the fear of
this food now quick side note this
enzyme down regulation is reversible
when we actually start to eat normally
again and reintroduce those foods but i
will speak more about that in a moment
but bottom line the result of dysbiosis
is actually more bloating in digestion
gas diarrhea or chronic constipation now
third is excess fiber consumption so
let's get it straight
that it's not uncommon for disordered
eating or eating disorders to stem from
very completely innocent and seemingly
normal
diet or weight loss efforts so it's
quite common for folks trying to eat
healthier or to lose weight to reduce
their consumption of refined carbs or
fats while increasing their consumption
of a lot of low calorie high fiber foods
like vegetables and fruit now consuming
a super load of fodmaps or even just a
lot of fiber-rich foods can cause excess
gas and bloating especially if there's
already dysbiosis or bacterial
overgrowth already present likewise
folks who are consuming a lot of high
fiber snack foods like bars and drinks
may find themselves bloated from the
added inulin fiber now note that there
is nothing unhealthy about inulin fiber
i want to make that very clear
in fact it's a prebiotic so it is
technically very healthy for the gut but
for folks with already compromised guts
it is a pretty aggressive fodmap that is
notorious for causing gas and bloating
so just something to watch out for if
you are already struggling with some of
those symptoms number four is excess air
consumption again it's very common
advice in the weight loss community to
fill your plate with high volume foods
to help suppress your appetite and
therefore reduce your intake of calories
but consuming a lot of air infused foods
like popcorn or rice cakes
chewing a lot of gum
or drinking lots of carbonated drinks to
like suppress your appetite can all
result in swallowing a lot of air and
while air
obviously doesn't have calories it does
add volume to your gut which again gives
the feeling and look of bloat now number
five is other additives in diet products
so sugar is one of the most demonized
ingredients in the wellness or diet
community so a lot of folks who are
trying to lose weight or even just be
healthier we'll swap it out for
something sugar-free but consuming an
excess of sweeteners can cause some
digestive distress most notably a lot of
the sugar alcohols like mannitol
sorbitol and maltitol other emulsifiers
found in low calorie diet snack foods
like carrageenan are more controversial
with some early animal evidence
suggesting an association with ibs and
dysbiosis now i would say that any of
these additives are unlikely to do harm
in moderation but
a lot of folks with eating disorders
tend to eat a small handful of the same
safe foods
every single day and if some of those
foods are chronically irritating the gut
obviously it's going to be hard to ever
get relief now number six is a reliance
on laxatives so laxative use whether
pharmaceuticals supplements like
magnesium or food based like coffee are
not uncommon fixtures in the lives of
folks with eds this may be because of
impaired bowel function from under
nutrition so folks kind of need a
laxative to go
or maybe it's to promote weight loss or
even to suppress appetite in the case of
something like black coffee but laxative
abuse essentially impairs the digestive
system's normal muscle tone resulting in
a lazy gut incapable of normal function
and as you can imagine this just becomes
a vicious cycle now number seven is
related to the brain gut access now this
one is pivotal because we know how
important the intersection of mental
health and digestive health can be so
recent suggests that in patients with
eating disorders specific psychological
gestures like anxiety tend to predict
functional gut disorders like ibs
bloating and constipation now it's
possible that a mental health disorder
is at the core here of both of these
issues and it's also possible that one
is perpetuating the other
so for example folks with eating
disorders often will have anxiety around
eating or eating certain foods that they
don't deem safe which can actually
manifest as physical symptoms to those
foods like bloating constipation and
excess gas
and finally there's the impact of
elimination diets now a lot of the diets
used to treat digestive disorders
are restrictive as
i know because when i started my journey
with my gut i had to be really honest
with myself that doing a full out low
fodmap elimination diet would have
likely triggered me and i know that
because my eating disorder from way back
20 years ago
actually originated with an innocent
elimination diet prescribed by a
naturopathic doctor and then it just
spiraled into a full-blown fear of food
literally all of these things that we've
just talked about happen to me and they
happen to so many others as well who are
just trying to feel better in their
day-to-day so what can you do to treat
your functional gut disorder without
further perpetuating your ed well tip
one unfollow any influencer who promises
to heal your gut with another diet and
just work with a teen who has experience
with functional gut disorders and eating
disorders if a practitioner does not
screen for a disordered eating or
ignores your history while prescribing
another really restrictive diet that's a
really big red flag folks
we cannot heal the gut
until we've addressed the eating
disorder and if this treatment is
happening concurrently it needs to be
handled by a really experienced team i
also recommend recruiting a loved one or
family member to support you and to eat
with you which will make it a lot easier
for you to get through some of the more
challenging points now tip two is to eat
regular meals and snacks at regular
intervals every day aka mechanical
eating so this is usually around three
meals and two to three snacks a day and
it is necessary for a lot of people to
regain hunger cues and to regulate
normal motility patterns intuitive
eating is just not really possible for
folks with active eating disorders so
keep in mind that it's normal for this
to feel very unintuitive at first now
tip number three is to work towards the
greatest variety of foods possible again
i acknowledge how scary this is
definitely going to feel but it is
imperative that we begin to expose
ourselves to these foods to help reduce
the food fears but also to help improve
bacterial diversity to get those
critters in your gut working in your
favor now tip number four is to consider
bowel training so i spoke to my
colleague and registered dietitian dasha
egg nulik who i will link to below
she told me that just like our bicep
muscles grow big when we do our bicep
curls weisenberg biclaps classic newton
bison burger bicentennial man our
muscles need training to go to the
bathroom too so she recommends sitting
on the toilet with your legs propped up
to create some pressure from your thighs
into the sides of your abdomen so she
suggests doing this first thing in the
morning for 10 minutes and then again
about 30 minutes after lunch and dinner
for 10 minutes every day
for about two months if you poop while
you're on the toilet great
toilet
sitting on the toilet if you don't
that's all good too think of this as gym
time for your bowel now tip number five
is to focus on self-care and stress
management a stressed mind means a
stressed gut so we need to really
address some of the root emotions before
we can really change any of the
problematic coping strategies tip 6
consider the right supplements ideally
here you want to work with a trained
expert and complete any relevant tests
to determine your unique supplement
needs so for example i did a gi 360
stool test and a sibo breath test myself
to get some hard data on which
supplements were best for me honestly
the supplement world is not perfect and
there's a lot of bs to get through but
for folks with disordered eating
tendencies i do prefer to add
supplements over taking other foods away
so depending on your symptoms this could
mean unique strains of probiotics
digestive enzymes supplemental acids
bile a fiber supplement like partially
hydrolyzed guar gum etc especially if
you're trying to wean off more
aggressive laxatives and just improve
your natural gut motility a really good
fiber regimen may be
key and then finally tip seven
manage symptoms without restriction
listen there are going to be hard days
emotionally and physically and i'm gonna
speak more to what to expect in just a
moment but try to manage the symptoms as
they come so this may be like a warm
bath or a gentle walk some yoga poses a
hot water bottle on your tummy or a cup
of peppermint tea when you feel
digestive symptoms emerge but remember
this too
shall pass
shall not
pass
but of course speaking of symptoms what
should you expect when you're trying to
heal your gut after or during an eating
disorder well
if we're being honest you probably will
feel worse before you feel better
emotionally and also physically if
you're practicing mechanical eating
you're probably going to feel
uncomfortably full between meals and
this can be very triggering for you
you'll also likely feel bloated gassy
puffy edemic and have other digestive
symptoms as your body just starts to
play catch-up on all of the enzyme
production shifts in fluids and
electrolytes and your gut's bacterial
profile recalibrates you may not be able
to tolerate every single food without
some kind of symptom at least at first
but according to all of my colleagues
who i asked and also the literature
symptoms will significantly improve
virtually in every case when you just
start eating enough calories enough
variety and you're able to manage your
fear and stress of eating remember this
is a long game but it is so
worth it for long-term food freedom now
i hope this video was helpful for you
guys and that you now have some great
tools in your toolbox for relief when
you're struggling with your digestion
and your relationship with food a big
reminder to of course seek out the
support of a trained dietitian some of
which i'm going to link to below and if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
if you have any other major questions
any other topics you want me to cover
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]